how's he doing uh you know how's his
spirit bro he [ __ ] he better than me
put it like that i'm not stressing
he popping that [ __ ] he talking like he
out on the streets you know what i'm
saying so
um
i know when he get out he's not gonna
have a problem getting straight back
into it like
he like a special one of a kind type
[ __ ] like i ain't never seen
nobody like him you know what i mean
yeah i thought one of the doper moments
that i saw
kind of the original verses was him and
rj and nobody got hurt at the novo yeah
i was fired that was fire
that was super far and he walked my game
up about a lot of [ __ ] too like like
what
just basically like uh
just me being like back to like being a
[ __ ] gang banger from the streets
like sometimes
the uh
the mentality of that carry over into
this but this ain't that and that ain't
this you know what i'm saying so like
being able to uh differentiate
the two you know what i'm saying
is is real difficult that's why you
don't see
a lot of artists like myself or with the
background like myself cracking or on
the scene
it's because they let the other [ __ ]
bleed into this [ __ ] and they're
separate it's too [ __ ] real you know
what i'm saying
and it took a while for me to understand
that
bro this is entertainment all these
[ __ ] doing this [ __ ] these [ __ ]
cripping extra hard and blood and extra
hard
it's a costume it's for the you know
what i'm saying so
like
and me coming from the real life
and like
shedding blood for this [ __ ] sweat tears
years of my life you know what i'm
saying actually putting in work [ __ ] and
like living it it's like
you know that part of me is hard to turn
that part of me off and accept
they're separate yeah except the
entertainment aspect of it like
[ __ ] acting super hard and like
they this and that you know what i'm
saying so
that's why a lot of uh
like real ones not in the mix you know
i'm saying so i just been learning how
to accept it you know what i'm saying
and um
you know